c'est dans ce bâtiment du chesnay que
les demandeurs d'asile devaient être
enregistrées en vue d'un accueil en
préfecture un projet désactiver vendredi
20 mai par le préfet les yvelines en
réponse aux inquiétudes des riverains
la plateforme d'accueil devait être
situé rue laurent gaudé à proximité
d'une école
ce qui a provoqué l'incompréhension des
parents d'élèves et de la mairie du
chéné même si nous sommes tout à fait
conscients qu'il est nécessaire de
pouvoir instruire le dossier des
migrants
ce lieu n'est pas du tout fait pour dans
une rue étroite du chesnay et contigu à
versailles puisque nous sommes en face
l'établissement de saint jean de béthune
qui a plus de 4000 enfants qui sont là
avec peu de trottoirs donc un lieu tout
à fait inadaptée philippe brillault
affirme n'avoir été au courant du projet
que deux semaines avant l'ouverture
prévue
plusieurs habitants manifester dans la
rue le 17 mai en face du bâtiment lors
d'une visite
même après son annulation le projet
divise cet afflux de migrants à
contrôler n'est pas du tout une source
de sécurité pour la ville
parce que ils font rien de mal quand
même si gens là c'était mieux qu'on
trouve un moteur droit que les médecins
après près d'une école d'autres endroits
où chesnais qui serait
faudrait pas ce genre de problème il
faut comprendre l'inquiétude des parents
le lieu aurait dû ouvrir la semaine du
23 mai accueillir des demandeurs d'asile
soudanais tibétains et marocains une
soixantaine par semaine essentiellement
des hommes âgés de 30 à 40 ans
l'association qu il ya en charge de la
gestion de la plateforme ne jugeait
pourtant pas l'emplacement inadapté les
personnes viennent lng roland situation
nous enregistrons dans les aidons à
remplir leur formulaire d'admission au
séjour
prendre rendez vous elles repartent avec
leur rendez vous et ensuite elles
continuent leur parcours d'un service
qui n'étaient pas de nature à provoquer
du désordre
la préfecture des yvelines n'a pas
souhaité communiquer elle cherche
actuellement d'autres lieux plus
approprié pour accueillir la plate forme
de co alia philippe brillault s'est
engagé à aider les services de l'état
dans cette direction